how do you make a horror film that
avoids sound let's take a look at the
opening of a quiet place to see how John
Krasinski both establishes a world and
puts on a master class in tension
building with one near-perfect
ten-minute sequence with just one title
card and for corresponding shots
Krasinski achieves the first role of an
opening establishing the world and how a
quiet place achieves this is through
minimal visual exposition although they
might seem pretty random the five
opening images actually tell you all
there is to know about the world the
title card hints at a major event that
has occurred before the film and the
next three consecutive shots affirm and
establish the post-apocalyptic world in
fact these minimal visual expositions
are everywhere from a child's drawing
the hints at the creatures
extraterrestrial origins to a newspaper
that explicitly states what the danger
is choosing to leave more out than in
lens the film a sense of mystery while
offering the bare minimum of information
to follow the plot the second role of an
opening is identifying the visual
language every film has a unique style
and tone in which it tells the story in
the case of a quiet place that language
is show don't tell this technique is
most evident in the opening sequence
mentioned prior the title card
establishes a specific time frame and
the next three consecutive shots
establish that law and order have
collapsed people have abandoned their
homes and society is in ruin
finally a wall of missing people
signifies that danger is still lurking
in the corners contrary to popular
belief a quiet place does not take
inspiration from the classic silent
films but rather modern visual films
while silent films that physically lack
sound rely on exaggerated visuals
emotions and movements to keep the
audience's attention visual films ignore
the present sound to rely on simple yet
precise shots and edits to visually
convey and
Meishan Krasinski refers to two main
sources of inspiration the Coen Brothers
No Country for Old Men and Paul Thomas
Anderson's there will be blood the
latter also features a 14 minute opening
sequence with no spoken dialogue that
can also be entirely understood without
any sound take a closer look at their
respective screenplays and the
similarities are even more obvious
visual films rely on these long and
specific scene descriptions that
visualize almost everything from the
props to the movement of the characters
the Temple of the edits and even the
direction of the camera this unique show
don't he'll approach and be identified
everywhere instead of having to explain
the daughter's disability all we need is
a single close-up want to establish that
making a sound can be dangerous this is
all you need to show this is also the
reason why the film relies so heavily on
reaction shots
more specifically characters reacting to
one another while a line that clearly
expresses a character's emotion might be
more convenient sometimes a gaze or a
change in expression can be enough to
deliver it more convincingly
in fact the opening is chock-full of
these reaction shots which establish the
relationship between the characters and
convey a range of emotions like
affection sadness fear and ultimately
dread which brings us to the final and
most important role of an opening
engaging the audience in a horror film
like a quiet place that's usually
achieved by scaring the audience except
this film has a crucial limitation in
that department
sound take any scene from a horror film
and watch it without sound and it will
most likely never feel as scary to get
around this limitation
Krasinski chooses tension over an
outright scare sometimes it's as simple
as showing who we need to worry about
right from the first image after
visually associating sound with danger
Krasinski delivers three key moments
that gradually build in tension and they
are all achieved in the most brilliant
way by not showing themselves whether
it's the sister jumping in out of
nowhere to catch a falling toy at the
last second or the family gripped in
fear by something the boy is holding
that we can't see Krasinski cleverly
uses the film's show don't tell approach
to deliver a unique sort of tension of
the entire ten minutes almost a minute
and a half is dedicated to this sort of
tension building up until the final
moment the boy whom the audience already
knows will be the source of trouble is
shot only from a distance or partially
hidden until that dreadful noise begins
off screen for even heavier impact the
reveal happens twice once to the ears of
the parents and then through the
perspective of the mute sister who
visually confirms the present danger and
as the film kills off the most innocent
and powerless of the bunch the audience
is once again reminded of the gravity of
the danger and the fact that anyone can
die at any moment
the reason why the opening to a quiet
place is so brilliant is that it allows
the film to go anywhere establishing its
unique world rules characters and their
struggles and traumas all in under ten
minutes because the role of an opening
is not to open just the film by to open
its story to unlimited possibilities for
its audience to enjoy
[Music]